ANU SRIVASTAVA:
Today, we're talking
about Google I/O announcements,
Applied ML Summit, and Cloud
SQL maintenance.
I'm Anu, and welcome
to This Week in Cloud,
where we serve you the
lowest latency news.
We're still basking
in the afterglow
of Google I/O. And did
you know that there were
tons of Cloud announcements?
Head to the blog for a list
of keynotes, topics, and links
to on-demand sessions.
There's everything from machine
learning, to cloud run jobs,
and even how to increase
your productivity
with Google Workspace.
At Google Cloud, we've
helped thousands of companies
accelerate their AI efforts,
empower their data scientists,
and extend the ability
to build AI-driven apps
and workflows to more people.
This includes everyone, no data
science or machine learning
background required.
So please join us June 9 for the
Google Cloud Applied ML Summit,
a digital event which
will bring together
some of the world's leading ML
and data science professionals,
all to explore the
latest cutting edge AI
tools for developing,
deploying, and managing machine
learning models at scale.
Register today.
Cloud SQL has now made
self-service maintenance
generally available.
This allows you the freedom
to upgrade your Cloud SQL
instance's maintenance
version to the latest version.
The benefit is that you can
receive the latest security
patches, bug fixes, and
new features on demand.
When combined with deny
maintenance periods,
self-service maintenance
gives you the flexibility
to upgrade your
instance according
to your own
maintenance schedule.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the Cloud.